une image vaut mille mots et certaines
nous laissent semble comme celle de la
dépouille du jeune alan kurdes y
photographier le 2 septembre 2015 sur
une plage sûr que c'est un petit garçon
qu'elle est bonne car sa main et colis
et si moi je pense une des raisons
principales pour cette image était très
très fort ces images là les jours c'est
vrai qu'à nous rentrer dedans mais est
ce que ça prenait cette image là l'union
européenne a ouvert les portes à des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
pour le photojournaliste ivanoh demers
il faut parfois montré des images du jeu
comme pour illustrer le 20 septembre
c'est une photo où ce qui était très
controversé parce que bon évidemment on
veut pas voir la mort fait que des gens
qui ont six thèmes photos qu'on n'aurait
jamais dû publier
moi je suis pas seul des images qui
contribue à changer les choses
les images de bourail et qui sont
devenus absolument iconique là c'est
plutôt un groupe d' images des sons des
images qui deviennent célèbres contenu
de jouey de l'ampleur des réacs des
réactions qu'elles vont auquel vont
susciter ou encore ces images du
génocide rwandais qui ont bouleversé la
planète
on a tous vu manger des cadavres tout
l'été un dindan dans les rivières que
j'ai encore cette image là maintenant en
plus j'ai perdu un peu ce sens humain
l'inde d'avoir la compassion stepped up
des images marquantes qui restent
pertinentes malgré le temps qui passe
c'est une photo qui est encore
d'actualité 52 habitants
alors ça montre la force de l'image
celles qui changent le cours de
l'histoire
comme cette attaque au napalm durant la
guerre du vietnam suite à cette image
l'a jamais reconnue ont dit ok
personnage ok ok on se retirait la
guerre il faut qu'elle devienne
véritablement une sorte de symbole fort
qui fasse l'objet d'une appropriation
collective c'est à ce moment là que
l'image peut être nageant de
transformation sociale au québec ou si
certaines fautes ont marqué l'histoire
on peut penser à celle de la crise d'oka
qui est une image extrêmement forte
une image de contrôle confrontation
l'image très littérale le
photojournalisme est apparu il ya une
centaine d'années avec les médias de
masse et malgré les difficultés la
presse aps à qui il reste toujours aussi
pertinent aujourd'hui ce sont d'autres
instruments ce sont des plateformes se
seront installés g
twitter qui vont jouer exactement le
même rôle mais avec des temporalités
complètement différente beaucoup plus
rapidement et à une échelle massifier la
force des images et de nous permettre
d'ouvrir les yeux sur le monde qui nous
entoure
ici n'est bien alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal